[MUSIC PLAYING]
PAUL KINLAN: Hi, everyone.
Welcome to our very first "Stack
Overflow" and Chrome
for Android Hangout.
This is the very first time
that we've done this.
I'm Paul Kinlan.
I'd like to introduce
Matt Gaunt.
Matt, do you want to say
hello to everyone?
MATT GAUNT: Hi, everyone.
PAUL KINLAN: Well done.
Cool.
So yeah, this is the first
of us at the moment.
So what we're trying to do with
this show is kind of show
you our workflow for how we
actually do with "Stack
Overflow" questions and how we
support the community inside
"Stack Overflow" for Chrome on
Android and Chrome in general.
So we're going to do
a couple of things.
We're also definitely going
to answer questions live.
I say "live." we did go through
and prepare the
answers for quite a lot of these
earlier today because we
didn't want this show just to be
full of "uh" and "um" and,
"Yeah, that's a bug." You will
see a lot of, "Yeah, that's a
bug." But yeah, I think we're
going to be quite cool.
If you hear in the background
today I've got some kids with
me just crying.
Don't worry about it.
They're just-- it's bed time,
and they don't like it.
It's fine.
But yeah, so we're going to
show you our workflow.
We're going to show you how
we think you should--
well, not how you should file
issues on "Stack Overflow,"
but what we think is a good
process for helping us help
you, if that makes sense.
Because sometimes, it's a little
bit hard to work out
what you mean.
And we'll just kind of
walk through that
flow of what we do.
So Matt, shall we jump straight
on to the "Stack
Overflow" questions?
MATT GAUNT: Let's just do it.
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah,
let's do it.
So you're going to see not
my face anymore, which is
normally a good thing.
So "Stack Overflow,"
here we go.
This is our special tag
that we've got.
Well, it's not a special tag.
It's google-chrome
and android.
They're two separate tags that
we've got inside "Stack
Overflow."
And this is actually
how we monitor.
And my day just normally
consists of me just pressing
screens like this and then
seeing what happens.
So we'll start off.
Shall we start off with
the first one, Matt?
MATT GAUNT: Yeah, let's just
do it, right from the top.
PAUL KINLAN: Right
from the top.
So this one has actually
been closed, I think.
But basically, the question is,
Chrome browser in Android
always renames the downloaded
file to download.bin.
And basically, what it's saying
is if the file is over
28 megabytes in size, then it
won't respect the name.
Now there are a couple of things
that we need to get
sorted with this is that
I actually think
there's a bug in this.
The question's been, I think,
closed originally, and so we
can't do too much with it.
But anyway, the general idea is
that there's a thing called
a download attribute on
[INAUDIBLE], which, if I load
up JS Bin now, we should
see one of the
examples that I've done.
Sorry, just--
I can't see the screen
properly.
File system demo,
there we are.
Now if I zoom back in, what
you'll see actually isn't the
answer to the question, but
there's this attribute here
called download equals log.txt,
and that actually
saves the name.
Now the interesting thing that
we've got about this is if you
go back to this question, I
can't really answer this
question because there's
not enough
information in this page.
There isn't any code.
There's just reference to the
fact that he uses IIS 7.5,
which is fine.
But we don't actually
understand how
the download is initiated.
And there's a couple of things
that you can do.
You can set the content--
the disposition, basically, on
the type if it's coming in
from the server.
But if it's generated from the
client, for instance, you can
do things like that anchor
attribute that we saw before
with download, you can set
the name from that.
And the thing I wanted to talk
about inside this bug in
particular is that there has
been a bug inside Chrome,
which is in stable right now,
so it's broken in the stable
version of Chrome, where if you
give a name [? in the ?]
download attribute, it doesn't
actually let you
download the file.
It starts up the Android
download manager but then just
kind of flakes out.
Now the really cool thing is if
you get the beta, which you
can find from Google Search, if
you get that beta, you'll
see it's actually fixed.
So if you actually specify a
download attribute on your
anchor, you'll see the file
is actually named.
And it won't be called
download.bin, which is what
you get it you don't name
the file at the moment.
So this one, it might
be fixed.
I think my kid's getting
told off at the moment.
So it might be fixed
in the latest beta.
But we're going to have
to check it later on.
And unfortunately, we can't
really answer this question.
So this isn't a bad question.
I know the guy's
got a problem.
We want to try and help
as much as possible.
But we can't really do too much
with this other than say,
you know, it might actually
be fixed.
Matt, do you have any other
thoughts about that one?
MATT GAUNT: No.
I must admit, I did actually
find it, I think it was a
couple of days ago I actually
experienced exactly the same
thing, so I have the feeling
it could be a bug.
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah, it
could be a bug.
And so what we'll do in a minute
is we'll try and show a
little bit of the process
that we go through.
Once we know a little bit
more, we can actually
reproduce the problem.
Actually, tell you what.
We'll go into this overlap
in slide transition.
Now this is on the other end
of a lot of information has
been provided to us.
You can probably see here,
there's a lot of list elements
and everything.
And then the guy says, if
you look at Firebug, the
attribute's applied.
I'm not too sure why he's using
Firebug with Chrome.
You can get a lot better
integration with Chrome using
the DevTools.
If you're in the Chrome
Canary, you can go to
chrome://inspect, and if you've
got ADB running, you
can actually see your
devices, and you can
actually debug the devices.
And I think Matt might be able
to show you a little bit of
that later on.
So this question here is, we
can't actually answer this
question either, unfortunately,
because when
you actually go and press the
site, I can't actually work
out what the problem is.
He says basically, it doesn't
transition exactly correctly.
So I think that this type of
question, some screenshots
would be really cool.
I know it's a little bit awkward
sometimes to get a
screenshot off the phone
and on, and it takes a
little bit of time.
But in this case, I couldn't
actually find out what the
problem was, so I couldn't
actually offer any help.
Which is a little bit
frustrating, because we want
to really help these guys
solve their problems.
But the next one actually is
a kind of interesting one
because we can actually
help out on this one.
And the question is, I can't
open local files from the
FileSystem API on my
Android phone.
So this one is kind of cool
because, Matt, I think this is
the one that we got the
demo for as well,
so we can kind of--
oh no, it's not, actually.
It's later on.
The two questions are
really similar.
And essentially, the person
wants to be able to take their
file from the file system.
In this case, it's an
XML HTTP request,
which is kind of cool.
So they're going to download
something from the internet
and cache it locally inside
not the database but the
FileSystem API.
And the FileSystem API is like
a normal Unix-based file
system so you can write data
to it and read data from it
and iterate through the
directories and all the type
of file structure that
we'd normally expect.
The interesting thing about this
is I actually think this
part of the question is a little
bit of a red herring
because it's basically anything,
I need to get the
array buffer and save it.
And the guy can--
I say the guy.
The person who did this bug
can actually save it.
And we know they can save it
because what they're saying is
that the file is visible
from the actual file
system inside Chrome.
So if you go to filesystem
Chrome, the URL forward slash
persistent, you'll actually
see the list of files that
have been offline cached.
Now the interesting thing here
is this is where it gets a
little bit more interesting.
Again, because you can see the
person is basically saying, I
want to save to a PDF, and then
I want to write to it.
And then when it's written,
we'll save out.
Now the interesting thing
is that this here
is the actual problem.
So the exact error message in
English is "Untitled, download
unsuccessful." Now this,
unfortunately, is the bit that
we really, really need
to know and we really
need to try and debug.
And everything above it doesn't
particularly help us
that much when we're looking at
this, other than the fact
that we know that the
"download started"
notification happens.
So there's a couple of things
that happened here.
And if we go down to my answer,
basically, so I
answered this about four hours
ago, is that on stable, it
kind of works.
In beta, it does work, in the
sense that the stable version
of the program has this
attribute problem.
So the demo that we saw before,
this file system demo,
this is the code I recreate--
[HIGH-PITCHED NOISE]
PAUL KINLAN: That's my son
not liking going to
sleep at the moment.
So in this demo, basically, in
this actual question, we've
written this demo to try
and log the file.
And now if I press save
on the desktop, it's
a little bit awkward.
You might have seen at the
bottom of the screen, there is
the log.txt file, which if I
open, you're not going to be
able to see because
I'm sharing the
window and not the screen.
But it basically says,
hello world.
Now this works on a desktop,
but it doesn't work on the
phone in stable.
But if you go to the latest beta
version of Chrome, you'll
find that basically,
it works now.
Now the way that we answer this
question is basically
saying, it's not the
greatest solution.
In stable right now for the
majority of your users,
there's really nothing that you
can do about this problem,
unfortunately.
But in the beta, it's going
to work as expected.
And we've given the
demo beneath which
shows how it works.
Now the interesting thing about
this is I would normally
raise a bug.
But because I know I've raised
the bug in the past, and it's
been fixed--
MATT GAUNT: Paul, Paul, it's
getting a bit creepy without
having a face on screen,
I've got to admit.
We need to bring you
back on, man.
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah, do you want
to bring me back in?
Let me just jump out.
[CHILD CRYING]
MATT GAUNT: There we go.
PAUL KINLAN: The sounds of
the crying [INAUDIBLE].
So anyway, yeah.
So we basically find this
bug normally, and
we raise the bug.
And I'll show you how
we do that in a bit.
Actually, it's not that
interesting, really.
But then we go and find it, and
then we'll go and fix it
or get it fixed or prioritize
and escalate it.
Now the interesting thing about
this is we know it's
going to get fixed.
And that's all we have to really
do is say, it's going
to get fixed, and this answers
your question.
And if we give a demo to how
it's actually going to work,
that's going to be great.
Because the hardest thing
actually is parsing out what
normally happens inside the
JavaScript and HTML from a
question and trying to re-create
that in your
application.
So that's why we've given the
link into the JS Bin, to
answer your question.
MATT GAUNT: It's also a lot of
the times that it simplifies
things for us is if we already
a JS vid or a JS Bin link,
where someone's gone, here's
an example of the problem.
So I've taken the source code
that I would have put in Stack
Overflow anyway but just made
sure it's in a small sample.
The nice thing with that is
often, if you're working on a
production product, you can't
really put the code in.
Whereas JS Bin and JS
[INAUDIBLE], it means you can
condense everything
down to really the
core of your problem.
And that means we can take that,
fork it, play around
with it, adjust it, try and
diagnose the problems
ourselves and then either come
back with a fix or, like you
say, we get the opportunity
to go and raise a bug.
And then we can also point our
engineers to that as well.
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah, I think
that's the most important bit
is that whenever we
ask the engineers,
they cry like crazy.
But then at the same time
is they ask for a
reproducible case.
And if we give them an entire
web page, like an entire
application, they can't
break down exactly
what the problem is.
And if you can get a
reproducible case, that really
helps engineers actually try
and solve the problem.
And if you can't get a
reproducible case, sometimes
it means that the actual issue
or the logic might be on your
side of things.
So let me just jump out to
the previous question.
That was the one thing I really,
really wanted to
mention was, if you actually
notice, there's an issue on
the desktop but not inside
mobile Chrome, or the other
way around.
There was an issue on
the mobile Chrome,
but not on the desktop.
It's normally a bug.
It's not normally kind of
something different in the
stack or kind of
anywhere else.
It normally is the fact that
something is not working as
it's expected to work.
And a great case is this
download thing that we've just
seen before where, you want to
try and download some data and
give it a name, and it just
doesn't work on the desk-- it
works on the desktop, doesn't
work on mobile.
That's a really strong
indication that you should
raise a bug.
Now the interesting thing, so
normally what happens from
this, and I'm just going to
jump back to my screen, is
that what will happen is we'll
find a bug, but then we'll go
to [INAUDIBLE], I think.
The other way around.
No, that's not the one.
That could have been a really
dodgy site, [INAUDIBLE].
New, new dot, there we are.
Basically what happens is that
URL, that really short URL,
will take you to the place
where you can submit an
Android issue.
And the template you want
to use is Android.
And then you just basically give
us as much information as
possible, the steps
to reproduce.
If you're going to download a
file, for instance, you'd say,
click on this link.
I have this attribute set.
It doesn't download the file,
and those type of things.
And then the expected
and actual result.
The expected result isn't, it
should work, which is normally
what we get.
But like, if you expect to have
a log.txt produced, say
that you should expect to see
a log.txt file on your local
file system.
So that's one of the things we
use when we're doing the bug
tracking is new.mcrbug.
And that's the site which
I have no idea
what that one was.
That was just my typo.
So I'm going to jump back to the
previous question, or the
next question.
So this one's actually been
closed, but i did actually
want to answer this one.
Will Chrome on Android
eventually support Pepper, and
thus, the Flash player?
The basic answer, it's
not going to happen.
Unless some things change
internally, it's
not going to happen.
We want to make sure that
all the web pages
are completely sandboxed.
MATT GAUNT: And I think given
the way Flash has been going
on mobile, it doesn't seem like
many of the browsers are
really supporting it.
So it kind of feels like we
should be pushing the web
forward for more responsive
sites.
And it doesn't seem like Flash
really has much of a place in
there at the moment.
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah, it doesn't.
That's he easiest way
of saying it.
But it's not just Flash.
It's all the plug-ins as well.
We can't get the plug-ins
working across all these
devices properly.
He doesn't like going to
bed at the moment.
And so we can't get all these
plug-ins working across all
the devices.
And we want it to be a pure,
open web, and that's the way
that we're going at the moment,
and that's what were
trying to support.
So let me just jump back to the
screen, because I want to
also go to the next question,
which I think that we've got a
demo for at the moment
as well.
So there we are.
Next question, fetching a blog
in Chrome from Android.
So Matt, this is the one that
we've got a demo for, right?
MATT GAUNT: I believe so.
This is the--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
PAUL KINLAN: So I'm going to
hand across to you in a second
on this one.
But this is a really good
report, actually, because
basically, it says it works in
Chrome for Firefox on desktop
and Android, but not on
Chrome for Android.
And then we get a good
description of what's happening.
So basically, requesting the
video from somewhere on the
web of response type blob, and
then we're going to cache it
in the local file system.
So it's nearly exactly the same
as the question that we
saw earlier on in the show.
But it's a little bit different
because the actual
issue here is that once the
blob's been taken and made a
[? URL ?] of, we can't
attach it to the
source, the video element.
It works on desktop, but it
doesn't work on Android.
Now the interesting thing about
this is the answer here
is, it's a bug.
We've replicated the issue, and
we've found out what the
issue is, but we don't
have a fix.
Which is not a nice answer
to give people, but
unfortunately, it's the only
answer that we can give in
some cases.
So Matt, can we just jump onto
your screen so we can kind of
[INAUDIBLE]
through how we go about
testing this?
MATT GAUNT: So if i just jump
to my desktop, there we go.
So the first step is going to
be to go to Chrome Inspect,
because that's where we're going
to start being able to
debug this on the
Android device.
It'd be nice to say we
got video load by--
PAUL KINLAN: Didn't [INAUDIBLE],
sorry.
MATT GAUNT: If I hit Inspect
on there, and then I'm also
going to need to go, can I--
cool.
So what this is doing is
actually showing the web page
that I currently have
on my phone.
So if I quickly switch back,
I'll actually be able to show
you what my phone is doing.
There we--
no.
No, it's falling apart.
There we go.
So what we should be able to
see is, this is Pauls demo
that he's put together.
And basically, all it is, is
just a simple video page with
a link on it which says
load XHR, just there.
And when you click on that,
you'll see that the video
[INAUDIBLE] actually come in.
And the problem is when you hit
play, then it's going to
fail to do anything.
So this then comes
into the bug.
So if I dump to SlideShare
again, so the way we debugged
this was if we actually look
at the sources to the web
page, and I find where we
had the JavaScript.
This one?
Is this the one?
And it was as simple as putting
a break point under
this video source window URL.
So now, if I hit refresh on the
mobile device, we should
get to a point where when
I tap the button--
there we go.
So at that point, we're
debugging the JavaScript
that's running on the
mobile device.
And I believe this is what Paul
used to actually diagnose--
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah.
So the really nice thing here
was that we used a couple of
bits of Chrome.
So I use tab sync a
lot inside Chrome.
So I have a desktop, my
desktop instance.
And I'll test it,
make the JS Bin.
And in this case, we just
literally copied all the code
from the actual "Stack
Overflow" question.
I had to put my own video
in and make it
cross-origin enabled.
That's not part of the question,
but we just had do
it to make it work properly.
So we copied all the code in.
And then I tested
it on desktop.
And I just had the debugger
open, went into it.
And it worked.
The video gets cached locally,
or the object gets created and
then attached to the
video, and then you
can play the video.
And it's a nice little video of
me smiling and all of that
type of stuff.
So what happened then is that I
then open up my device, get
my device open, and use tab sync
so I can just pull the
page up straightaway, rather
than type the URL in.
And then just connect in, as
Matt showed you a second ago,
via the debugger, via Chrome
inspect into the device.
And then once it was in the
device, I basically just
tested it to see whether
it worked.
And everything worked
exactly the same, so
all the events fire.
No errors fire at all.
So it's not a problem
with the JavaScript.
But when you press play,
literally nothing happens.
And if you actually attach a
normal video to it, it just
plays like normal.
So it should work.
It's not an unsupported
video format
that's causing the issue.
So it was using WebM,
which is fine.
So that's pretty much
all it was.
So we can take this code,
and then we make a bug.
And if you look at the issue
that we've raised, or the
issue that's on the Stack
Overflow site, we've linked it
directly to a CR bug
that we've created.
Now the CR bug itself might not
be one that the engineer
goes off and fixes.
They might get it merged
with a couple of
other issues fixed.
But normally, this is what
happens when we know that
there's some functionality that
is missing on the site,
for instance, or inside
Chrome on Android.
We'll then go and raise the bug
because we know there's a
difference, and there's not
something that we can tell the
user or the developer to go off
and fix, because there is
actually no other way that they
can work around this.
And it's unfortunate, really,
because the developer can't
actually fix that problem.
So the answer always tells
them, it's a bug.
Unfortunately, right now,
it's the correct answer.
And then once we have a fix, we
might go back to the issue
and then re-edit the answers so
that we can say, hey guys,
this is now fixed.
And this is how we fixed it.
And it's nothing
to do with you.
It's always not you,
basically.
So there we go.
Right.
So there were a couple
of other questions.
Allow me to jump into another
one, which I know that we've
got an answer to, at least.
I'm going to screen
share again so
everyone can see the question.
There we go.
So there's a couple here.
There's a WebView HTML5
audio length.
Unfortunately--
so the WebView work is going to
take a little bit more time
for us to investigate because
we need to make an app which
uses the Android WebView and
then test it out to see if
it's working.
And there's not a whole lot of
code that we can copy and
paste inside this,
which is going to
speed up our diagnosis.
So I'm not sure that's going to
get answered any time soon,
within the next couple
of hours.
But one I really want to bring
this to, there's two in quick
succession on June the 16th
about data URLs and base 64
encoding and audio, which
is really weird.
Normally, these two things never
happen at the same time,
but both these questions
have come up.
So here.
This says, the following snippet
plays while in Chrome.
Base 64 data, something which
we can't replicate because
it's specific to their
application, but audio dot
source, the data file, and some
base 64 encoded data.
Now we got audioPlayer.load and
audioPlayer.play, which
are the two functions that
you should expect.
And again, the person says, hey,
this works on desktop but
not on Chrome for Android.
So I'm going to jump
across to, I
think, another question--
inside JS Bin.
This is a good advert
for JS Bin.
It's a pretty awesome tool.
Here we go.
[INAUDIBLE]
on my screen.
But this is how I replicated
the issue today.
So basically, I set up my page
with a button that says play,
an audio file, and
[INAUDIBLE].
There it is on the page there.
So you can see it there.
Now there's a whole bunch of
base 64 data across here,
which is a WAV file that's
been encoded.
And then I basically try and
replicate exactly what the
person has actually put in.
So if I press Play here--
[SOUND EFFECT PLAYING]
PAUL KINLAN: I don't know
whether you can hear it, but
it's actually playing some
audio in the background.
Now let me just jump out of this
demo because there's not
a huge amount extra I can
show you on the screen.
But the interesting thing here,
this is another one of
those examples where
we debug locally.
And you don't even have to debug
too much locally because
you can hear the sound
getting played.
But once we have this
reproducible case, we go and
then hook it up to the
actual device, Chrome
Inspect, plug it in.
And then I go to my device, my
tab, pull the sync in, and
then get back up that way.
And then we connect the
debugger just in
case we need it.
But because we've loaded the
page, I just press Play.
It's not loading.
Now the thing is, now we've got
the debugger connected, I
basically go and look at the
page to see if all the
relevant events fire.
They do.
So we know that things are kind
of starting to happen a
little bit, but no
audio comes out.
And it feels very similar to
the video issue that we saw
before where you're attaching a
different type of URL to the
video source element,
but it doesn't play.
Again, I think it's going to be
in the same type of area.
So to cut a long story short,
there's not a huge amount I
can say about this, is basically
we think there's a
bug inside the actual loading
subsystem, or the load and
play subsystem of Android
for Chrome.
It's going to be down to an
engineer to try and find out
exactly what that is
at the moment.
But the only thing that we can
say to developers is, we think
it's a bug.
We've raised an issue with
the exact reproducible
case that we put in.
So the two people who have
raised this issue today, the
same audio issue, one is a data
URI, and one is about
base 64 encoded.
They are actually the same issue
when you look in the
line bits of this, is that
we basically just
said, it's a bug.
Go and track it on this.
Put any other of your use cases
that you need to get
fixed and follow it.
There's not much else
that we can do.
And because the developer wants
to generate their audio
file on the client side, which
is why they generate the data
URIs and the base 64 encoded
URIs, there's not a huge
amount that we can do to solve
this issue at the moment,
other than say that.
We could suggest that they go
put it on a server somewhere,
but it's not quite right.
I think we're probably getting
close to time.
Is that right, [? Keith? ?]
MATT GAUNT: Yup, it
looks like it.
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah, two or
three minutes left.
So we can answer a couple
more questions.
Matt, I know you were looking
at the media JS or
MediaElement.js question.
MATT GAUNT: Yeah, so this was
just a really simple question,
which was essentially, if I
open up the website for
MediaElement.
What happened was someone had
noticed that when the load up
the video, there was a button
that was basically going to
the wrong part of the screen.
It was basically wrapping
onto another line.
And it's one of those things
of, it could be perhaps
something in the layout's
gone wrong.
It could be a hard-coded
value.
And essentially, all it was was
if you go and look into
Chrome Inspect again, so I'll
share my screen and inspect my
mobile device, where I've got
the website up, we can
actually dig into the source
code for this site.
And if I start driving down
through all these things,
where are we?
This one.
Down here.
We start drilling down to the
actual control, I believe.
There we go.
And what you'll see here is we
got a couple of buttons.
So if I switch you guys over to
my mobile device, you'll be
able to see what I'm actually
getting up on my screen.
[INAUDIBLE].
What you should be able to see
is that little white speck in
the middle of the blue.
That's the full screen button
that should actually be just
up here on the right
hand side.
And if I start digging around in
the DevTools, what you can
start seeing is, I
actually start
highlighting certain elements.
So right there is the
full screen button.
But if I actually move the width
of this in DevTools,
it'd just be one
pixel smaller.
You'll see that the actual full
screen button has just
shifted over.
And basically, this is dead
simple to do using DevTools.
Because all I had to do
was just play around
with a value here.
And that's actually just
shifting the pixel off by one.
So it sounds like the problem
that they're getting is just
the library's just doing
an off by one error.
So it's a case where maybe they
can commit a patch or
something like that.
But it's simple enough
to do, when
you've got Chrome Inspect.
Nice and simple to diagnose.
PAUL KINLAN: That's
pretty cool.
I know we had some conversation
as well today
about whether this was a Chrome
issue or a Chrome for
Android issue or not.
Because I've seen a bug as well
in the past where, on a
new viewported page, the Full
Screen button is minuscule.
So that's where my confusion was
originally when I saw this
was, it's a Chrome for
Android issue.
But as you've seen,
it's actually a
MediaElement.js issue.
I suppose we could probably
raise the bug.
We just have to make a decision
about what's going to
get the best level of support
for developers in the end.
MATT GAUNT: Yeah, thanks,
[INAUDIBLE].
PAUL KINLAN: I mean, Matt,
you could fix it.
Cool.
MATT GAUNT: But yeah, this is
generally our flow, isn't it,
when it comes to fixing bugs?
It's a case of taking the code
and assessing what's wrong.
But it's also whether it
is something else.
PAUL KINLAN: At the moment--
I'm supposed to wrap
up, in a way.
This, Stack Overflow has become
one of our primary
mechanisms for supporting
developers.
And we have to make a decision
like, Chrome for mobile, or--
Chrome for mobile hasn't
got its own tag.
And what we find is that
developers will have Google
Chrome as one tag and then
Android as another.
And we found that there's a
good intersection of those
questions that we can actually
support directly for
developers, in that sense.
So we have a team of our
developer advocates and
engineers, who we take it on a
rotation to actually start
answering and making sure that
we're trying to get as much
support as possible for the
developers out there on it.
Because we're not like dedicated
completely to
support, if that make sense.
We've got a lot of
other issues.
But we want to make sure that
all the developers who
actually have questions we can
answer in a reasonable time.
So the Chrome for Android
platform is the best one that
you can develop on.
Yeah, so if you do have any
questions that you want to get
answered, we're trying to
bootstrap the community on
Stack Overflow to get
more and more people
answering those questions.
But I think for the foreseeable
future, it'll be
me, Matt, Jake, Chris Wilson,
and Pete, and a couple of
other people as well, just kind
of providing the support
to make sure it's there.
Because Chrome for Android
is a new product.
It probably has got some bugs.
And we want to help you work
around them or work--
fix your products in case
it isn't a bug and
it's a fix in logic.
But right now, today, there's
been three bugs raised to the
Chrome team because of the
questions that came through
Stack Overflow.
So yeah.
I think that's it.
Matt, do you have anything
else before we finish?
MATT GAUNT: No, I'd just say
it's just ridiculously useful
for us also to kind of find
these weird quirks that you
guys are experiencing, becaues
it means that we can find ways
to fix them and then also
feed them back.
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah, exactly.
And if you can, if you can help
us help you, more code
and samples, if you can.
But if not, we'll just
delve down and dig
down into the problem.
So thank you.
And see you again soon.
MATT GAUNT: Cheers, everyone.
Bye.